- [Announcer] We brought
together seven queer people.
- I am a queer person.
- I'm a queer person.
- [Announcer] One is a liar.
Who is the odd one out?
- Scale of one to 10, how gay are we?
- Eight.
- I'd also say eight.
- I'm a nine.
- Yeah, I would say a nine or 10.
- A seven.
- What makes you a seven?
- Because I like both, like,
I'm in like a poly couple right now
with a guy and a girl, so...
- [Kacie] Okay, period.
- What do you like better?
- I think I'm...
this is one of my like first relationships
of the last two years.
So, I'm like kind of more open.
They're like an older couple.
So I'm getting more torwards--
- You're not answering
what you like better.
- I like girls a little more.
That's why I was at a seven.
- [Travis] Okay.
- When Travis was asking questions,
he was kind of snappy with
me and like calling out
that I didn't get to
his point straight away.
- They were very nervous
when they were speaking.
I just feel like they were skirting around
every single question
that was being asked.
- Wait, wait, wait.
But what's your sexuality?
If you don't... sorry.
I cut y'all off. I'm so sorry. (laughs)
- I'm bisexual. I'm poly and bisexual.
- Okay, fair.
- So when did like
everyone kind of discover
their like sexuality, I guess?
I was raised as a Mormon.
I had like a secret relationship
with one of my roommates in college.
After that, I just
couldn't deny it anymore.
And I was like, okay, I'm gay.
- I was 18.
I experimented with a
girl for the first time,
and a lot of my previous life made sense.
- Nice.
(group claps)
- [Elizabeth] Yeah. (laughs)
- I came out the womb queer,
and I've been queer ever since.
- So are you a golden gay?
- I'm a golden gay.
(Keith laughs)
- Good for you.
- Travis was very to the point
and like not saying a lot
which also made me a
little suspicious as well.
- I came out at 14, but
I'm not a golden gay.
So, there... I went
through a straight period.
That's what I call it.
I identify as polysexual,
most genders, but not all.
I hate CIS men, so.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm a golden gay.
I'm a golden gay,
but I don't really
identify as gay anymore so.
- Yeah, same.
- And in college, I started
like experimenting more
and I grew up in Ohio, which
is like very conservative.
And like, my mom was like
very traditional Asian.
So it kind of just stayed to
me until I kind of moved out.
And then I moved to California
like a year and a half ago,
and it's been more open,
and everybody's been really awesome.
- Welcome to Cali.
(everyone laughs)
(bell rings)
(tally clicks)
- Even though they are non-binary
that doesn't automatically make you queer.
(tally clicks)
- Travis is playing a very
attack kind of gameplay.
He's not really like
giving us any details.
(tally clicks)
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] We have a three-way tie.
- Oh, whoa.
- Okay.
- [Announcer] The tie is between
Netia, Devens, and Travis.
- [Travis] I was shocked, flabbergasted.
- [Announcer] So I'm gonna
give each of you 30 seconds
on the clock to state your case.
And then we'll do another round of voting.
Netia, starting with you.
- Well, if you guys vote me off,
that's like super homophobic.
I'm just gonna say.
(everyone laughing)
I'm just high femme, so like,
if you're distracted by my clothing,
you're just like, "she doesn't look gay,"
it's because this is like
gender affirming to me
to present myself in
like a super feminine way
while being gay and not
being like masculine
and just like, yeah.
(bell rings)
- So I guess I'll go over
maybe nightlife or something.
I guess I'll start like Beaches
and then go down to Rocco's
and end at The Abbey, because
you gotta end at The Abbey.
I met my, the couple I'm
with right now at Mickey's,
they were like married
together and then found me.
What else?
Hamburger Mary's, anybody?
Friday? Friday night drag. So...
(bell rings)
- [Travis] That is no
way to defend yourself.
List every gay bar you know?
Okay. Makes no sense.
It was a terrible defense.
- If you have 30 seconds,
like talk about how much
you love penis or something,
like don't say you love Hamburger Mary's.
- I'm married to a man.
So, I don't know if
that tells you anything.
I've been queer since 12.
I have a Winnie the Pooh
tattoo and a Totoro tattoo.
Come on, guys.
(everyone laughing)
That's as queer as they come.
(bell rings)
(tally clicks)
(upbeat music)
- Just because you know the
names of like a gay bar crawl
doesn't mean anything.
(tally clicks)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer buzzes)
- Sorry.
(everyone laughs)
- Good game, good game.
(everyone claps)
- Good game play.
- [Devens] I mean, it kind
of sucks I was eliminated.
I don't think they let me talk enough
and kind of explain myself.
- So do you guys all
like identify as queer?
Is that like an open term?
- Are you gay, like what do you guys?
- I go between queer and bi.
I was really comfortable with bi,
but then my partner from high school
actually came out to me
recently as a trans woman,
and my current partner is a trans man.
And so the label "bisexual"
has kind of just like
started to feel a little
like pushing me into a box,
and I go between, that's
what I'm trying to say.
- It wasn't until I
was like in my thirties
that I discovered there was
a whole other side of me
that I could put a name to
and identify.
And it's such a more full...
- [Kacie] It is.
- [Zach] Yeah, I completely agree.
As I started dating more male partners,
I started using the label "gay"
just because it felt easier
until very recently.
It's so rigid, and sexuality is so fluid.
And while I have identified
as gay for a long time,
I have come into terms with the fact
that I am also attracted to women.
I'm attracted to trans individuals.
- [Elizabeth] I don't blame you. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah women are beautiful.
- They're gorgeous.
- Women are beautiful.
- And I feel like with me,
like, identifying as a lesbian,
after being like so strict on non labeling
when I was in high school and stuff
because of like that
suppression I went through,
I finally feel like I
belong to a community
(everyone agrees)
which is like so stupid to
say, but in retrospect...
- Labels can be liberating or
they can be like conforming.
- Yeah.
- It's whatever's is
true for you as a person.
(bell rings)
(tally clicks)
- He was very quiet.
Like I knew from the beginning he was gay
but at the end of the round,
Elizabeth was just like more
forward about her queerness.
(tally clicks)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer buzzes)
- No, (chuckles) it's okay.
It's okay. I get it.
- We appreciate you.
- Good game, good game.
- I love your fit by the way.
- Thank you.
- Sorry, I never said it.
- I thought it was gonna
happen. I didn't say much.
- [Announcer] If you think
the mole is still in the box
and you wish to continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
(Kacie sighs)
- Wow.
- I think we got it.
- I like, yeah. I don't
know who I would...
- [Announcer] Yeah? Okay.
- [Elizabeth] I feel, I feel good.
- Is the voting already done?
Like we're concluding
'cause I don't wanna throw
myself under the bus.
- [Announcer] No, voting's done. Yeah.
- We're done now.
- So I'm like kind of sus of you.
- Ooh!
- Only because like you have
the stereotypical piercings.
- Okay.
- I'm just like, they would
put a gay stereotype...
- That's fair.
- We're done, too.
- It's because I believe you're gay.
- Thank you.
- You're just like too gay.
- Okay.
(Netia laughs)
- I was sus of you because my
gaydar just wasn't going off.
- [Zach] Hmm.
- [Travis] That was all there was...
- [Netia] She's like
totally lesbian stereotype.
- Yeah. Like I definitely
get gay vibe from you.
- Thank you. (claps)
- But you could be farmer's market girlie.
(everyone agrees)
- You know what?
This was an issue in my past relationship.
- You were just like, I
thought you were a horse girl.
(horse neighs)
(record scratch)
- Oh, no!
(everyone laughs)
- No, like...
- That's horrible!
- [Netia] To affirm you
fully, you look like every
stereotypical white
gay that I ever seen...
- [Announcer] You called
Elizabeth a "horse girl."
(Travis laughs)
- I did. I mean...
(Elizabeth laughs)
- I find that offensive.
- I'm gay. Y'all, I'm gay.
(everyone laughs)
I'm not a horse girl.
I came onto set, and I was
the only one in Birkenstocks
like with my dogs out barking.
And I was just like, well, I mean at least
I like have the lesbian shoes,
but I didn't think that made me
like a farmer's market horse girl.
- [Announcer] Just to
confirm, we feel confident?
- I feel good ending.
I'm nervous, but I'm...
- We're good.
- [Announcer] Okay.
- If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box, and you lose.
If the lights turn green,
that means the mole was
voted out, and you win.
(suspenseful music)
(everyone cheers and claps)
- [Netia] We love it.
- I knew y'all were gay.
- [Netia] I know.
- [Announcer] Now we're
gonna have the mole
reveal themselves on the count of 3.
1,
2,
3.
- Yeah.
(everyone claps)
- Wait, are your pronouns
actually they/them?
Okay, you don't identify as queer?
- Yeah.
- So what were you faking?
- The backstory?
Well, I am from Ohio, and
I am a poly relationship.
So just like the...
- Just the man part.
- Yeah, everything else is pretty good.
- So is the poly couple
that you're with...
- [Travis] Two girls?
- a straight... or like two
girls or a man and a woman?
- So I have three relationships
but both my partners are bi.
- Are you an ally, though?
(everyone cheers and laughs)
- With those nails.
- [Zach] If you're questioning yourself,
allow yourself the space to explore
and feel okay with not
knowing for a little bit.
- I lost someone very
close to me a year ago
who was a young queer person.
And I just want every
young queer person to know
that it gets better.
And there will become a point in your life
where you are very confident
in being part of this beautiful community.
- If you find the queer community,
you have a place in it immediately.
You're immediately accepted into it.
Take some time to think it over,
figure out if you're one
of us, and if you are,
congratulations, 'cause we're fantastic.
- It's reparations from
the straight community.
- It is reparations!
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, yeah, right?
- Happy Pride!
(everyone cheers and laughs)